inspecting a research lab in Beijing
president xi jinping urges scientists to
develop vaccines and treatments what he
called China's most powerful weapon in
the battle against the corona virus
outbreak some 80,000 people have been
infected nationwide recovered patients
have been urged to donate blood but new
cases are slowing on Tuesday Beijing
reported its lowest number since January
several people caught the virus in Iran
in Italy prompting some Chinese cities
to quarantine all travelers from
countries affected by the outbreak
including South Korea where more than
5,000 are infected China has sent half a
million mosques to Daegu South Korea's
hardest hit city South Korean leader
moon jae-in ordered all government
agencies into emergency mode declaring a
war against the virus the country has
entered war against the infectious
disease as the crisis in Daegu and North
Yungas has reached the highest point in
Japan shot the stripped supermarket
shelves of toilet paper and other
essentials Tokyo has confirmed almost
1,000 cases Prime Minister Shinzo Arthur
says he's ready to boost government
spending to protect the economy we were
scrutinized the impact of the corona
virus on the global and Japanese
economies if further steps are deemed
necessary we will take action without
hesitation Australia's central bank cut
interest rates to a record low about 40
cases have been confirmed their Chinese
cities brought to a standstill by the
virus are coming back to life some
provinces are preparing to reopen
schools as early as next week the
government says the outbreak is under
control but with many tough restrictions
still in place nationwide it seems to be
having trouble convincing the public to
be alert but not alarmed Katrina you al
Jazeera Beijing